Russell Rothstein, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
Very good, Michael.
Glad to be here.
You're calling all the way
from Modi'in, right?
I am. I am.
So, we're in our Israel office
halfway between Jerusalem and Tel Aviv.
Why Modi'in?
I know Tel Aviv.
I know Herzliya.
Why Modi'in?
Well, Modi'in is actually one of Israel's
fastest growing metropolitan areas.
It's also, for those of you
who are interested in history,
the place where the Maccabees started
thousands of years ago.
So, it's a great place.
It's very inspiring.
It's a place where
the small group of soldiers
fought against a much larger enemy.
So, it's really well suited
for building a startup.
Of course. Of course.
And actually,
I came to visit you in the offices
about a year and a half ago.
And it's a wonderful, beautiful area.
And definitely a place
that I need to come more often to.
But Russell,
before we talk about IT Central
and talk about covid-19
and what it's like to manage a team
during this crisis,
I want to go back a little bit
about your journey from Harvard,
MIT, MIT Sloan,
talked to me a little bit
about your journey into the business world
and into entrepreneurship.
What was that trigger for you
that got you thinking,
Okay, I want to be part
of this tech ecosystem?
Yeah, sure.
Well, I'd say it even starts
before college.
I'm from the Bronx, born and bred.
And going into college,
I didn't know that I was going to study
computer science.
That's what I did my bachelor's
in computer science.
I didn't know that
at the time going into it.
I really only until sophomore year
did I really hone in on computer science
and found I enjoyed the course in there.
And so, I just followed that
went with that journey.
And then worked in a technical capacity.
I worked at Oracle
as my first job out of college.
Deploying Oracle databases,
and Oracle applications,
do a lot of [--] work.
But at the time,
I really started to think about
what my passion was.
What my strengths were.
I really enjoyed that interaction
of solving problems for customers.
Deploying databases.
Deployment that applications.
That point where I actually,
getting into something
that's valuable to them.
I liked interacting with the customers.
I didn't want to just be sitting
in front of the computer all day.
I really enjoyed talking to the people
and understanding them not just socially,
but also professionally.
What they're doing.
What's this database all about.
What's this application all about.
And then started to think about
from my career.
And it led to me to go to
more of a business, less technical route.
I went to MIT.
I started at MIT, or began my MIT journey
in a master's program,
studying technology and policy.
Studying telecommunications policy.
And then, I decided
to take an additional year at MIT.
A third year and got an MBA from Sloan.
So, I did masters and MBA.
And really so, since then,
I moved into the business marketing side
of technology
after I graduated business school.
Very very cool. Okay.
And now, we're talking about IT Central.
So, you're in Modi'in
and  you're running this virtual startup.
Talk to me a little bit about B2B reviews
and understanding software.
What is IT Central?
And what problem are you trying to solve?
Because I think it's a problem
that especially young entrepreneurs,
we don't really get exposed yet
to this area.
We're much more, I think,
we get exposed much more to B2C.
Talk to me a little bit about that.
Exactly.
So, it really began, like you said,
it began with my expertise and knowledge
of the B2B space.
And even within B2B,
the enterprise technology space.
So, I worked in my career
in enterprise technology.
Enterprise software companies.
I mentioned Oracle.
I worked at companies
that developed software
to manage performance of applications,
managed networks.
The kind of software solutions
that larger businesses
would use at banks,
insurance companies, large retailers.
And so, that's the world
that I began to really know well.
And so, on one hand,
I was developing this knowledge
and really intellectual curiosity
and love of the enterprise tech space.
But in addition,
I was always really intrigued
by social media.
And a lot of the new trends
going on in B2C.
I was a very early user of Twitter.
Going back a long term history,
I mean, I created my own website
in the late 90s.
Wow.
And so, I've always been interested
in the conversion of the two.
And so, the story
behind IT Central Station
really began in 2011.
And I was having dinner
with a friend of mine, Naftali Marcus,
and he's now the co-founder
of the company.
But at the time
we were just talking about ideas.
Did you know
when you were talking about ideas
so you had an intention
to start a company together?
Or, are rolling off ideas
off of each other?
Or, how did that work?
Yeah. Listen, there's different types
of entrepreneurs out there.
There's entrepreneurs that
every day you talk to them,
you meet with them in like every hour.
They're coming out
with really interesting ideas.
They're always,
they're just overflowing with ideas
for companies or startups.
I'm not that kind of person.
Okay?
My ideas for a startup
come once every 10 years.
Okay. But I have this idea again
back in 2011.
And I invited Naftali
who I had a lot of respect for.
I have a lot of respect for.
I had some ideas to get him involved.
And so, really I explained to him that.
So, we're having dinner.
It was in Manhattan.
We're having some hummus and kebabs.
Of course.
Exactly.
And again,
this was a time where there weren't
such things as B2B review sites.
So again, before we go
into intellectual problem,
what is the problem space
that you're trying to solve?
So, there aren't B2B review sites.
What does that even mean?
As a young consumer,
I don't even know
why we need a B2B review sites.
Exactly.
And that's what I explained
to Naftali over this dinner.
I said, here I was,
and I just traveled to New York,
I stayed at a hotel,
and I used reviews from TripAdvisor
to help me make a decision
about which hotel I will stay at.
It's really important.
I mean, I think it's obvious that
before you make
any important purchase today,
you want to go online
and read reviews.
Whether those are Amazon reviews,
Yelp reviews, what have you.
But am I in the business world
where I was working with
enterprise technology professionals.
So, these people,
these IT manager, CIOs,
enterprise technology folks,
their responsibility
was to choose software
or choose technology for their business.
A new cybersecurity solution
to help their business stay more secure.
Some type of new software
to help them build applications
better, faster.
A new type of application
to manage their business.
And they did not have access to reviews.
They did not have access to easy way
to tap into the knowledge of other people
who had already checked the market,
who already researched solutions,
really use some of those solutions.
But Russell, what my intuition
is guiding me is saying,
when I look in to buy headphones,
there may be 500 different types
of headphones
and all sorts of price variations.
And it's a really congested market.
When I think of a cyber security solution
for my company, maybe there is like
three or four good solutions, not 500.
Maybe I'm wrong.
But my intuition just says that maybe
because there's less reviews,
it's a little easier.
Or less product, it's a little easier.
But maybe I'm wrong.
Well, it depends.
Enterprise tech is a huge market.
It's three trillion dollars.
Three trillion dollars is spent every year
on enterprise technology solutions.
So, there are some markets
where there are,
take IT service management
and many cybersecurity.
There are dozens of solutions out there.
It's very confusing.
And different than headphones.
Very different than headphones.
Because headphones,
you have same use case, right?
You're using it to listen to your music.
And maybe they've got
some different features.
These different types
of enterprise technology solutions
are more complex.
And so, it's oftentimes
it's comparing apples with oranges.
Or one type of apple
with a different type of apple.
And so, its very complex.
So, even if there are just a handful
and oftentimes there are dozens,
but even they are just a handful,
it can be a very
complicated buying process.
And, so it's really helpful
to talk to people
already gone through that
and then gone to the market.
So again, going back to that dinner,
I said,
"How could it be
that I had all access to all these reviews
when I was just choosing a hotel?"
which not the most crucial decision
in the world for me.
but business people or technology people
are basically betting their career
on this technology solution.
Because if it works well,
they're the hero.
If it doesn't work well,
it can be damaging to their career.
And obviously, you can save the company
millions of dollars
to make the right technology purchase.
Where you obviously,
you can lose lots of money
if it's the wrong purchase.
It's still important strategic.
And so, that's how we got
to starting IT Central Station.
It's the leading review site,
real authentic reviews written by
enterprise technology professionals.
So, it's not B2C.
And even within B2B, it's not targeted
for the small medium business market.
It's targeted to
enterprise technology buyers
with their unique needs.
How do you get people
to write the reviews?
So, how do you get this,
the CIO or the VP R&D to come in
and then say,
Yes, I purchased this
cyber security software.
We've been using it for three months
and we're happy or unhappy and here's why.
Yeah. Yeah.
So, it's really important
because it's not a question of just,
you don't want just to have
a really short review, right?
I mean, that could be helpful.
That might be good for me
when I'm choosing a hotel.
I just want to know,
a lot of people say that,
So, you want to know
how many stars out of five.
You don't necessarily care about
the little details.
Exactly. Exactly.
So, for but for enterprise
technology buyers,
it's much more important
to have that in-depth content
because someone evaluating technology,
enterprise technology for their business,
they have a whole lot of questions
that they want to ask.
They want to know.
Again, what is the use case
that they're using it for.
How is the implementation.
What's the business case.
What's the return on investment.
Where is the room for improvement.
What other pieces of advice.
What's the best licensing strategy
to work with this vendor
Right.
There's a lot of information there.
So, our strategy is not only
to get reviews,
but focus on the quality of the reviews.
So, it's not a numbers game.
It's not getting millions and millions
of reviews.
It's getting that reviews
that are generally valuable
to help people make buying decisions
in their enterprise technology purpose.
And so, the kind of incentive
that we put in place is very different
than the kind of incentives
that you might see in B2C review site.
So B2C review sites,
first of all, there's sometimes issues
with fake reviews.
People giving out gift cards.
And  all those things
to incentivize people.
And it sometimes creates bad actors.
We've decided to do
zero financial incentives.
We don't pay people to write reviews.
And that's really important.
Really,really important not to pay people
to provide reviews.
And really it's observing,
If you're familiar
with the Maslow hierarchy.
Of course.
Right. So, of needs.
So, the bottom are the more
those of physical needs.
And so, to motivate people by giving them
either financial incentives.
Write a review we'll give you
a $10 gift card
or a five dollar Starbucks card.
That's of the low part
of the Maslow hierarchy.
Right.
The upper part of the Maslow hierarchy
is self actualization.
That's the top of the Maslow hierarchy.
So those are the levers that we pull.
So, we provide ways
for our viewers to see
how providing review helps the community.
The altruism is a very strong force
for many people.
Two is, it's a way for you to be seen
as a thought leader.
Especially in today's market.
If you're a technology person,
how do you promote yourself.
How do you get your promotion.
How do you get your next job.
It's by showing that you're knowledgeable
about a particular solution.
If you're really an expert at this
salesforce implementation
at the cybersecurity deployment,
whatever it is, then you're going to be
more valuable out there in the market.
And so, we're able to use these levers
to get people to provide
more in-depth reviews.
How we find these people?
So, there's really two ways
that we find people
who are providing reviews.
One is members of our community.
We have 400,000 registered members
in IT Central Station.
And so, they're actively
providing reviews.
We do solicit reviews from them.
They're answering questions.
Because we've focused on that
community aspect of it,
they stay engaged with the platform.
Wow.
One is our process
to continue and solicit reviews
from our community.
And the second aspect is
there are lots of technology companies
that simply want more reviews
of their products.
And that's part of our business model.
We're fully transparent about it.
It's called reviews.
It's a service.
And so, the way that will work is that
if a company wants more reviews
of its products,
it will use a service subscription program
with IT Central Station.
They will provide us
with lists of their customers.
And then we,
as an independent third party,
completely neutral,
collect those reviews from them.
And it's a win-win
because you both get the reviews
and you get,
Exactly. Exactly.
The technology vendor
does not have any veto rights.
They don't get to edit the review.
So, it's very possible.
And it happens.
It happens sometimes.
Those reviewers are actually critical
of the product's that they use.
But that's part of the game.
Because if they're all five star reviews,
it's not credible at all.
You all know that, right?
You've go to a page on Amazon.
It happens all the time.
And I see all these reviews
and they're all positive.
And it's like,
Okay. Something's going on here.
And then you see a couple
of the one stars
and they're there in length,
and then you feel something is fishy.
Yeah, exactly.
But if I see a lot of like
four star reviews,
this was really good,
but it didn't work for me in that.
But that's the most credible review.
And that's where we aim for
is to get those credible reviews
that provide both,
this is what's great about it,
but also there's the room for improvement.
I love it.
I remember somebody
back in the in middle school
or high school.
They told me that it's always much better
to get a 97 on a test than 100.
Because 100 means that the test was easy.
You just ace it.
If it's a 97, it means
you worked really really hard
and it was a really hard test
and you still got a good score.
So, I think it's exactly the same thing.
You want to get those scores
and those five.
You don't want to just get all five
because that diminishes the value
of those reviews.
Russell, what I want to transition also
to a little bit about work from home.
Because we're almost out of time.
But I want to hear a little bit
about your leadership style.
And covid is unfolding.
You're still running the team.
What do you do?
How do you as a leader
come and approach this crisis?
Yeah. So, there have been
a few guiding principles.
I think the first is compassion.
Covid has affect
many people in the world
from a health perspective,
from an employment perspective.
And we're fortunate
here in the company
we've grown since covid.
We did not have any layoffs.
We do not have any pay cuts.
We've grown, we're hiring.
We're continuing to hire.
But still, it starts with compassion.
Again, we're fortunate
none of our employees
have had any serious, to my knowledge,
health issues as a result.
But it's always knowing that whether
people might have a family member,
a friend, what have you,
who's affected by it.
And so, it all starts with compassion.
And to articulate that.
So, that's number one.
Number two, is communication.
So, I really had to ramp up
my communication with the team.
Because we shifted
from being in the office
to working from home.
We're now back in the office.
Many of us.
But for a period of time, obviously,
we were all working remotely from home.
And so, it's really about
overcommunicating.
So, I would do some things
that I hadn't done previously.
I was sending WhatsApp messages
to the entire team.
We were doing
some special types of videos
to keep the team entertained.
And obviously I would have more
frequent meetings with my cabinet,
my management team, with the entire team.
So, we just increased communication flow.
That was also really important.
Not to underestimate the challenges
of working from home, right?
On one hand, for some people,
some people really like it,
but it can be very tiring.
It can be very tiring to work from home.
And really just want to be there
and support the staff,
support the employees.
So, those are the things that we did.
We did some fun things,
had some fun along the way as well.
A couple of staff
had to go into quarantine.
So, we had a rule that
anyone goes into quarantine,
gets a pizza sent to their home
to feed their family for the night.
So, we sent out a bunch pizzas
and then people would then
take pictures of the pizzas
and share it with their team.
So, it became this fun company activity.
So, to come up with those
kind of creative things that we did.
Russell, that is so so cool.
Thank you again for being
so generous with your time.
This is so interesting.
And I learned a lot
over these past 20 minutes.
Before we leave,
I'd love to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Yeah. I'd say,
always be learning.
That is something that
I've always had a thirst for learning.
It's one of the values
of our culture credo
here in the company.
Always be learning.
We're all here in the company
it's a mandate to always be learning.
The funny thing is
when you get to be my age,
what you do is you learn
that the more you learn,
the more you don't know.
So, I'm in this now cycle
where the more I keep learning,
the more I realize
I don't know so much
and there's so much to learn.
So, it can be sometimes
quite a challenge.
But that's something that I think
is really a driver for who I am.
Very very cool.
Russell, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
Best of luck with both about the covid,
but also with IT Central Station.
It sounds really incredible
what you guys are doing.
And I love the different
intrinsic motivations
and the thought processes
behind how to get this to be,
to create actual value
and not just artificial value
on the surface of it.
And it sounds like this idea
behind growing a community
that actually cares
and actually wants to help
and wants to be shown and seen
while creating value for them too
is an incredible accomplishment.
So, Russell, thank you very much.
Thank you, Michael.
It was fun.